[Music]
in previous updates you could see us
making a pizza oven from clay and we
built a pizza around it
we used this place for friday pizza
nights and during the week to work
but one thing that has always been
bugging us is that we only have these
wobbly tables they shake around and
don't have a polished surface
not the best place to make pizza
also we tried baking in the kitchen but
it really becomes a mess the dough
sticks to the wood and everything gets
floured definitely not a solution
it will also help to have a dedicated
space for office work during the week
and then by moving the actual tables
next to the kitchen it will be easier to
set up lunch and we won't need to take
office stuff out during meals anymore
so we're gonna build a pizza table it
will be a big heavy table with a granite
stone on top because it's a local
product and smooth so good for the dough
so let me show you
[Music]
normally i make joints and i glue them
together for a very strong connection
but there's actually no straight wood
and there's no planer so i need to find
another solution
so i'm gonna use bolts instead that
makes it a bit more simple first i made
some sketches in my notebook to put all
my ideas together and then i built a 3d
model
[Music]
the table is actually quite big it's two
and a half meters long 90 centimeters
wide and one meter high
and there's a big
granite stone on top and it will maybe
wait a hundred kilos so the the base
like the construction need to be very
strong
so i hope everything goes well but we
surely will find some challenges on our
way but let's start
[Music]
first we need some materials so let's
see what's on top of the workspace
[Applause]
wood there are a lot of leftovers from
other projects so it will be nice if we
can use it
then you take this
[Music]
[Applause]
okay
these beams are
they actually are from the womb but they
were not good anymore too much bending
so they replaced them so now we're gonna
try to use this for the table
[Music]
the legs will be 95 centimeters long and
we're gonna use this gap to make the
joints for the other beam
time to cut
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all the wood is cut we all collected
over here but it's very annoying to work
on the ground so i'm gonna check if
there's someone who wants to make a
working table
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
now we have a nice table thanks to frank
so we can continue the work
[Music]
so here we have the legs made out of the
beams of the deck
um they're not all the same so i'm gonna
cut it all the same and then we can try
with this prototype i made
this will be the joint for
the table
so to show you
this will be
like this
and then the tabletop comes over here
[Music]
so
[Music]
so now the six legs for the table are
ready now we can continue with the frame
for the table
[Music]
we will be connected like this
and
now i'm gonna cut it with a saw all
lines together so this will be a nice
gap
where this can fit in
um yeah so let's start
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm going to route all the edges
make them smooth and clean
and make them a happy
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
we have arrived to the legs now and they
also gonna get a smooth edge
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay we have all the parts sanded and we
make a nice round edge so next step will
be assembly all the parts together with
some screws and i will use some glue for
extra strong connection
and it's pretty hard to do this on my
own so i'm gonna ask for more people to
help
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
it's fitting it's fitting as you see
it's fitting it's just a bit too high
but that's on purpose because then we
can get this japanese
pool saw
[Music]
easy
[Music]
i'm that heavy
[Music]
okay so while emma i still finishing up
the last touches of the table frame
we are gonna flatten the area where the
table's gonna be placed on
[Music]
okay
lovely people here we are
so while emma's taking off the last
edges of the table we will be having the
next step oiling it and
we're getting closer to the end
[Music]
[Music]
when i was a kid i used to pick the wasp
calls from the oak tree with my death so
we could make drawings
mixing these with water and rusty nails
gives a very black ink as a result it's
the acid in the oak tree what gives the
reaction and it protects the tree from
insects molds and forest fires
for me reason enough to test this on the
pizza table
[Music]
so now we will filter out the paint that
has been soaking for a couple of days
[Music]
so you have your self-made paint turned
out quite good so now we're gonna apply
it to the wood and see if it sticks
[Music]
here we are emma asked us to pick up the
table top for the pizza table we came to
the granite company we will fit the
table top in the van and go back to camp
come on people
[Applause]
and we did it they always finished
okay so now the pizza table is ready
it was a
pretty big challenge but it all went
good i would say so now we can enjoy
pizza night
[Music]
i want some pizza in my cheese
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i'm gonna put it
[Music]
do
[Music]
you